you're listening to episode 15 of
storycast 21 i'm jane secker the uk has
a long history of exploration however by
2016 only one astronaut helen sharman
had traveled space bearing the colours
of the uk flag
no britain had ever experienced the most
demanding and perilous experience of
space flight until one january morning
in 2016.
this is tim peake britain's first space
walk
my name is tim peake and i'm an
astronaut with the european space agency
[Music]
i had a six-month mission to the space
station
on the 15th of december in 2015.
by the time you take the elevator ride
up to the top of the rocket you're
completely focused on the mission ahead
of you
major tim is ex-army air corps and a
former helicopter test pilot with more
than 3 000 flying hours but it's taken
another there's huge amounts of
excitement and anticipation
you know things might go wrong
and you're just hoping really that you
know today is is going to be okay
the day of carefully timed choreography
began with tim leaving the hotel where
he's been quarantined so he doesn't get
sick
i'm thomas moore i'm the science
correspondent i was there with tim peake
in baikonur cosmodrome kazakhstan
and it was great to see
you know the indian flag patch on tim's
arms as he got into the capsule sat
there grinning giving the thumbs up
really it's a it's a case of just being
overwhelmingly excited about what is
about to happen
we were there with rebecca
and tim's boys a second service
and we could see it the excitement on
their face but also the concern and you
have to remember that
there are no guarantees in space
[Music]
i was about a kilometer away standing
with the team from sky
not only was the flame blindingly bright
but the noise was so loud that it
reverberated in our chest
after six years of training tim peake
finally ripped through the kazakhstan
skies just 45 seconds after launch his
soyuz rocket was nearly seven miles high
and travelling at more than one thousand
miles an hour
so obviously your acceleration builds
and builds and builds up to about four
g's and that's when you're really pushed
into the back of the seat
you've got to get up to 25 times the
speed of sound rebecca and the boys are
spellbound we're about um you know 150
kilometers up in space and the rocket is
almost horizontal because you haven't
got that much more altitude again
and nine minutes into the fight the last
rocket engine cuts out and tim feels
weightlessness for the first time a brit
is back in space
[Music]
you know you feel like a complete novice
when you first get into that environment
you're not quite sure what's going on
it's it's actually hard to control your
body because your legs and arms are
floating all over the place the soyuz is
in orbit at an altitude of 140 miles
mission control must now do it some to
catch up with the iss orbiting 250 miles
above the earth the first engine burn
moves the soils from its insertion orbit
up into us i had a six month mission to
the space station
the science program never stops it's
going 24 7 365 days a year and as a crew
member your job is to pick up those
experiments the process is repeated to
move it into the same orbit as the iss a
side thruster then i've always been
fascinated in pushing the boundaries and
when i launched the space i i
desperately wanted to do a space walk i
knew that there was a chance of doing a
spacewalk but you're never guaranteed
one so we just see if we can pick up
where they're at in the operation
[Music]
so to give you an idea of what you're
looking at um the front of the space
station where it's kind of flying
forward around the earth
that's the columbus module the japanese
module and very
shiny reflecting lots of light
then you move your way back to the main
truss and that's like this sort of
corrugated metal structure where the
solar panels are mounted
that's the length of a football pitch
and then as you move further back down
the space station you're looking towards
the russian segments which are smaller
diameter and painted white so the space
station kind of changes color as you
move down probably standing by for
contact fund has been confirmed
and the visiting vehicle officer here in
houston confirming contact and capture
has occurred
so tim copper malenchenko and
timothy peake now uh docked to the
international space station that uh
coming at so tim was with two other
astronauts
there was a nasa astronaut called tim
copper
and the russian commander was yuri
malenchenko he had been to space many
times whereas tim peake this was his
first mission well the station was
flying 252 statute miles uh over the
country of india so again when you
arrive on the space station uh you get
you know you get a huge sense of
satisfaction from being able to just
push off with one finger float down the
space station and end up exactly where
you want to go
it can only be totally weird to sleep
while floating in a sleeping bag
while down below you see the earth
spinning gently below you
well there we can see tim peake on the
big sky news wall
station this is sky news london how do
you hear me
[Applause]
yeah i think what's happening now is
he's talking to nasa he's talking to
london and uh hello to uh everybody at
the national space center leicester i
hear you loud and clear
fantastic tim it's great to join you
thank you so much for joining us i've
always been fascinated in exploring what
we can do better
and everything you touch is just cutting
edge technology
but not only was tim peake the first
britain to travel to the international
space station he had this dream of
walking in space a perilous undertaking
of course and the pinnacle of space
flight floating tethered to a space
station while it orbits the earth at 17
000 miles an hour i was quite fortunate
there's something broken on the space
station one of the solar panels so we
had to go out and replace that component
in order for that part of the solar
panel to work again
for me it was the view of earth that
motivated me
okay guys uh let us talk for just a
second everything looks good just hang
out for a second and we'll give you
final words we still got 17 minutes of
working eclipse my spacewalk was on the
15th of january in 2016.
we actually spent the whole morning
preparing for our spacewalk we get into
our suits quite early we go into the
airlock
this work by coperin peak
is required to properly seat uh the
replacement sequential shunt unit you're
obviously concerned that everything goes
as smoothly as possible so you do
everything in your power to prepare for
it
it's a bit like a rock climber planning
a very difficult rock climb internal
short back november 13th what's the body
position going to be how am i going to
get across that challenging obstacle
what's an alternative route if that
route doesn't work out
you have to go to the very very furthest
edge carrying this component the size of
a small fridge and we could only change
it during darkness because there was
live electricity flowing down this panel
so we had only 40 minutes of darkness as
the iss orbits the earth where we could
safely get this job done
[Music]
forward i think that will help being the
first britain to undertake a spacewalk
it didn't really weigh on me
[Applause]
i was in the airlock and all i was
thinking about was i've got to get all
of this equipment out to tim copera
without any of it getting tangled
okay if i'm coming out
okay
just watch the
line as you come out yeah
when we're leaving the airlock we've got
a couple of people talking to us there's
scott kelly inside the space station and
that's what's called the iv crew member
and we're also talking to mission
control okay
[Music]
when i go back in
and they will run the entire space wall
[Music]
okay
tim's in constant communication with
mission control back in houston they
regularly talk to both astronauts
reassuring them telling them
how they're performing against the clock
whether they're on schedule
on a space walk it comes down to
individuals to concentrate to focus and
to not make mistakes
you're also operating an environment
where if something does happen you have
limited time to put it right
you know our spacesuits could probably
keep us alive for about 30 minutes if
there's a small hole in the suit for
example
but if we rip our glove more than six
millimeters that's it game over our suit
just cannot maintain enough pressure to
keep us alive
[Music]
so you're constantly aware of where
you're putting your hands looking out
for sharp fragments that are out there
not forgetting to tether yourself to the
space station every time you stop and
take your hands off a handrail
[Music]
and that's when scott kelly said hey you
know tim it's great to see that union
flag exploring perfect spaces
all over the world and and it really
kind of sort of shocked me out of my
zone and i thought you know what you're
right this is an incredibly proud moment
and i was quite glad he said that
because i was able to
cherish it a bit more
guys we got good ku we're watching
sunset right along with you three
minutes until we get started here
we've had lots of problems with bolts in
the past that don't release properly and
so pieces of equipment despite changing
them out have a function and i do see us
getting a little ratty on the com that
should last for about the next five
minutes so all these things are going
through your mind you have got to have
complete awareness of what you're doing
but at the same time what's your crew
member doing where are they have they
checked in within the last couple of
minutes you know you're responsible for
their life too
so it's an enormous amount of
concentration focus that you have to
keep going for eight hours
[Music]
um so when we when we managed to change
it out in the one night orbit and we got
the word from mission control literally
about 10 minutes later you know guys
we've got we've got good power with that
solar panels back online it was a huge
relief and it was really satisfying
that's perfect framing right there we
like that and now i can afford to just
you know relax enjoy the view take some
photos
to get out of the relative safety of the
international space station and see
the earth below you mother earth that
blue and white planets slowly rotating
beneath you
and there's nothing between it and you
you are
all too intense and purposes just
falling towards it knowing that if a
meteorite hit you you would die
if you somehow managed to snap the
tether that
ties you to the the space station you
would float out into the vacuum of space
the amount of water just strikes you on
planet earth when you see it from space
reflecting all this wonderful sunlight
and then of course you're aware of how
fast you're traveling around
you're seeing all continents pass
beneath you amazing colors the sahara
desert is just this wonderful orange
glow
you pass over south america and you get
the lush green of the amazon
you're seeing these features of earth as
you you've kind of seen them on an atlas
but you're seeing them with your own
eyes at 400 kilometers down beneath you
and then when night comes everything
just comes into this tiny bubble of
what's in front of you with your two
headlights your entire world shrinks to
just a small pool of light
so at night time if you look up you'll
see a bright strip of milky way which is
absolutely beautiful
and then when the likes of towns and
cities come out you get to look down on
that as well and see all these signs of
human habitation
when you're on the space wall just
things are constantly changing and it's
you know sunrises sunsets are magical to
see as well as we continue to watch tim
peake being assisted out of his extra
vehicular mobility unit we know living
on earth surrounded by nature
clouds by our atmosphere by our
environment
it's very easy to to forget that if you
just go a few kilometers above you there
is a complete vacuum
which will kill you in less than 60
seconds
and when we're out in space and we look
at that atmosphere we see how thin it is
it really brings home just how
vulnerable we are as a species as life
on earth is vulnerable you know it's
reliant on that atmosphere to keep going
so i think your perspective certainly
does change when you see earth from
space
it's an awe-inspiring view
standing by for physical separation
after careful checks for air leaks
mission control gave the order to
release the hooks clamping the soyuz to
the space station
undocking confirmed
are the six months on the iss which is
remarkable to be part of a dynamic team
to be contributing to something that you
know has such benefit to humanity so
it's an enormous privilege to be there
only when at a safe distance did they
ignite the engines the moon providing a
stunning celestial backdrop it's
something that i hope that we will you
know keep going as in terms of our
research station in low earth orbit and
we'll continue that partnership that
will take us to the moon and
subsequently onto mars down to earth
with a bump
tim peake was back from a 78 million
mile space odyssey
best rider peanut ever truly elated i
mean
just the smells
of earth
[Music]
as of 2021 nasa remains committed to
returning astronauts to the moon by the
end of the decade in addition to
advancing a human mission to mars
tim peake britain's first spacewalk was
recorded by tom gillespie production and
sound design by rob mulhern for more on
this episode go to sky news dot com
forward slash storycast 21.
next time a television recording team
find themselves under siege in one of
the world's most luxurious hotels
and no one was coming to get us it was
really quite bizarre
all the indians were calling friends and
i said look guys you've got to just text
we don't want them to know we're here
and how many are here and what's going
on said please just go to text everyone
just went silent
but we could hear people being
um
killed playing for their lives and then
you know being shot and their bodies are
being thrown over the stairwell and they
were piling up down below we got all
that from all the iphones and stuff like
that
[Music]
you